je n'ai pas de portefeuille à partir de
là je n'ai pas à courir à la recherche
d'intérêts fiscaux je n'ai pas souscrit
et le président de la République s'est
félicité du succès de l'emprunt
baladure il faut une politique de
relance de la consommation mais pour
consommer il faut avoir de l'argent il
faut éviter de laisser en bord de route
des Français qui seraient des Français
de deè zone François miteron a précisé
qu'il fallait prendre d'extrêmes
précautions pour les privatisations de
la snekma de l'aérospatiale d'Elf et
d'Air France il faut protéger notre
capacité d'achat et de production
énergétique a dit le président de la
République depuis plus de 12 ans tout a
été essayé tout ce qu sa le gouvernement
actuel en matière de chômage doit être
autant que possible servi car il faut de
la continuité dans l'effort et François
mitteran de conclure si l'on fixe la
conquête de l'emploi comme objectif
prioritaire on a raison il ne faut
absolument pas que la sécurité sociale
soit atteinte et qu'il y ait une
médecine de riches et une médecine de
pauvre sur la réforme de la loi Fallou
François miteron a précisé qu'elle
pouvait réveiller la guerre scolaire
cette réforme attend depuis 143 ans elle
pouvait attendre octobre cette réforme
de la loi Fallou selon le président
mérite une grande
réflexion le président juge normal que
Michel Rocard s'il reste à la tête du PS
soit virtuellement candidat à l'Élysée
François mitteran a eu également cette
réflexion les choses se feront en leur
temps il n'y a plus qu'un an et 10 mois
avant que ne s'ouvre ma
succession